we have a Jamie Foxx update after he was
hospitalized last month for an
undisclosed medical complication at the
time it was rumored to be a possible
stroke he really listens to me I mean
I'm not the boss boss you are the boss
well just three days ago the Oscar
winners family including daughters
Corrine and Annelise were photographed
at a Chicago Rehabilitation Center
specializing in treating patients after
a stroke spinal cord or traumatic brain
injury
wave any type of brain trauma has to be
taken seriously and often patients will
likely require needing help with walking
or relearning to talk or some may have
memory deficits the rehab center is
among the best in the country but with
Jamie b as daughter Corrine said playing
pickleball there well the center does
have an Adaptive Sports and Fitness
program we play ping pong well you're
gonna play Pickleball incredible the
fact that he can play Pickleball the
motor coordination seems to be more
relatively intact but the concern can
potentially be in the language area or
the speech areas of the brain Jamie's
reportedly been at the center since late
April which is around the time when
Corrine talked about brain health on her
podcast how does the brain heal itself
when it has some form of damage neural
plasticity enables the brain to recover
function after stroke or other forms of
brain damage it's unknown when the 29
nine-year-old recorded her comments but
she's been by her dad's side stepping
down from beat Shazam to help him both
announced they'll co-host the fox game
show We Are Family premiering sometime
next year pretty typical about 12 to 20
days in a rehab if they're planning a a
game show the overall prognosis and the
recovery of Jamie is going really well
and hodakotb is revealing daughter
Hope's prognosis after the four-year-old
was rushed to the ICU for a mystery
health issue in February this is what I
want to put out in the universe quote
Hope's doing much better I think it's
going to be a longer road but she is
doing great that's where the Today Show
co-anchor told reporters last night two
months after her youngest returned home
following more than a week in the
hospital Hoda made the comments at the
Webby Awards where the winner gave this
customary five-word acceptance speech
listen
and love love love
bye
[Music]